- Many people around the
world are asking themselves,
"How many doses of the COVID
19 vaccine they'll need
and how often?"
- [Narrator] Protection
from vaccines starts waning
after a few months.
So the US and other countries
are expediting booster shots
to fight rising infections.
- We have booster shots
for the whole nation.
- [Narrator] People in a handful
of places, including Chile
and Israel have even started
getting boosters of boosters.
- I'm getting the fourth shot today
'cause I think it's
important for protecting.
- [Narrator] Here in Tel Aviv,
researchers have been
conducting clinical trials
for these fourth shots.
- The good news is preliminary results
from the Pfizer trial
show a fivefold increase
in antibodies, researchers hearsay,
"That could mean increased protection."
We did not see any severe,
significant adverse events.
- [Narrator] But
scientists are still trying
to determine just how effective
these fourth doses are,
and how long that protection can last,
and some warn against
rushing to add more boosters.
- Regarding a fourth dose,
I'm not convinced at all.
I think that's why it shouldn't
be done in a clinical trial.
- [Narrator] So we looked
at what the scientists know
and why many epidemiologists say,
"Repeated doses shouldn't
be given out so quickly."
(background chatter)
Scientists say, "Vaccine
effectiveness starts to decrease
at around six months," and
that's where boosters come in.
In simple terms, this is how it works.
We all have these Y-shaped
molecules called antibodies.
They are produced naturally
by our body's immune system
to help stop the virus from intruding.
When a virus enters our system,
our body responds in a number of ways.
The first offense is by creating
unique antibodies that bind
to it in order to
neutralize it or remove it.
The COVID-19 vaccine helps the
body to make these antibodies
and evolve any existing ones,
and to keep the virus out.
But after a while, numbers can dwindle
and that protection fades.
Booster doses increased the
number of antibodies again,
and continue to advance
the body's understanding
of the virus.
(background chatter)
Now, researchers in Israel
where COVID vaccination started earlier
than in other countries,
say, "The protection
from those boosters is waning too.
In as little as three
months in some cases."
Professor Gili Regev-Yochay
and her team are working
to determine how effective
a fourth dose will be
in renewing immunity loss
after the third shot.
- People here that came
to this study are only four
months after the third dose.
- [Narrator] The doses are
being tested on staff members
who received a third
Pfizer shot in August.
Shira Galper is a
physician at the hospital.
- I didn't have any large
concerns participating
in the trial.
I think I would take
vaccine every six months
if that's what medically is recommended.
- [Narrator] The trial has
around 300 participants in total,
half are receiving another Pfizer shot
while the rest are getting Moderna.
- The logic behind this is that we think
that there may be a benefit
of combining vaccines.
We're hopeful that we will
see something additive
when we give or boost the immune response
with something slightly different.
- [Narrator] The shots
participants got were the same
as are used in normal vaccination cycles,
Pfizer, Moderna, and Johnson & Johnson,
which produces a single-dose vaccine,
all said they were developing
Omicron-specific vaccines,
but those updates could
take months to be produced.
For now, drug makers
are approaching additional
doses differently.
Pfizer CEO, Albert Bourla,
said, "A fourth dose
is not necessarily needed."
Well, Moderna advised that
those who have had three doses
of its vaccine, may need
a second booster by fall.
(slow music)
For these researchers,
it will also take time
to draw our conclusions
that can answer questions
such as, how long protection
from extra boosters can last.
But like many other
experts around the world,
Regev-Yochay already says four shots
shouldn't be given out to everyone.
- I would I think that probably we need
to save these vaccines
only to really the people
who are very vulnerable and needed,
and not give it out to
the whole population.
- [Narrator] In other words,
people who are
immunocompromised, for example,
are more exposed to the risk
of getting seriously ill,
even after vaccination, but
for healthy individuals,
some scientists argue two
or three shots already
offer enough protection
for the worst symptoms.
That argument comes as research suggests
the Omicron variant may
cause milder infection.
Hospitalizations associated with Omicron
in the US are lower compared
to prior variants, though,
it could be too soon to
make definitive conclusions.
(slow music)
The number of daily coronavirus
cases reached new highs
this winter, in countries with high rates
of vaccination are taking
different approaches
to second boosters.
Some are racing ahead.
Israel has offered them to at-risk groups.
(Naftali speaks foreign language)
Well, Chile and Brazil are also moving
to provide additional doses,
after initial campaigns
use less effective Chinese-made vaccines.
(Sebastian speaks foreign language)
But government experts in the UK
said a second booster
shot isn't a priority,
and EU regulators said
frequent shots could
weaken the immune system.
- It's not something
that we can think should
be repeated constantly.
- [Narrator] While the world
health organization cautioned,
blanket booster programs could, in fact,
prolong the pandemic.
- By diverting supply to countries
that already have high levels
of vaccination coverage,
giving the virus more
opportunity to spread and mutate.
(background chatter)
- [Narrator] For now in Tel Aviv,
researchers also recommend
taking more time for reflection.
- I hope that it's not going
to be a policy of giving it
to everybody, at least not
yet when we don't have data.
If we will learn that that's
really what's necessary,
it might change the story, but
I'm not convinced about that.